eine Woche lang verschwunden spurlos die
14 Jahre alte Josephine aus Aschersleben
in Sachsen-Anhalt in dieser Sendung
haben wir gestern zur Suche aufgerufen
und jetzt ist Josephine gefunden tot in
einer Garage auf einem Garagenhof lag
ihre Leiche ein Verbrechen und wir
wollen einmal einen Blick auf die Karte
werfen wo genau hat sich dieses
offenbare Verbrechen abgespielt der
Fundort der liegt in Sachsen-Anhalt das
ganze Verbrechen spielt sich ab in
Aschersleben und die Leiche von Josefine
sie wurde eben dort in dieser Garage
gefunden recht sehen Sie das
eingezeichnet der Fundort und der ist
ungefähr zwei Kilometer entfernt von
diesem Treffpunkt dort wollte sie sich
treffen mit ihrem Ex-Freund dort war sie
verabredet und wir haben auch gerade
links auf der Karte noch gesehen ihr
Wohnort also die
Tat offenbar die hat sich abgespielt auf
eine relativ kleinen Fläche auch hat es
eben über eine Woche jetzt gedauert um
Josephine josefine's Leiche zu finden
dort in Aschersleben wir gehen genau
dorthin in diese an diese Garage in
Aschersleben zu unserem Kollegen Tilo
scholtysek grüße Dich Thilo
guten Morgen sag uns einmal hier wo die
Polizei bis sie tief
verzeihe verzeihe Tilo in noch eine eine
Frage natürlich zum Einstieg vor allen
Dingen wer und wann wurde Josephines
Leiche dort an der Garage in der Garage
gefunden
Josefine ist Leiche wurde gestern gegen
14 Uhr 30 von
Anwohnern gefunden die hier auch eine
Garage haben der Komplex ist sehr große
gibt es 160 Garagen die meisten sind
relativ verfallen wir haben hier gerade
Leute erzählt die Garagen haben die auch
vor Ort sind dass es hier oft Einbrüche
gibt viele Garagen stehen leer und
offensichtlich in so einer leer
stehenden Garage hier hinter mir wo
alles abgesperrt ist wurde die Leiche
gefunden die Polizei hat die ganze Nacht
durch Ermittlungen aufgenommen die
Feuerwehr kam hat den Tatort
ausgeleuchtet damit die
Gerichtsmediziner die Ermittler hier
ihre Spuren sichern konnten wir wissen
dass heute weitere Suchmaßnahmen hier
geben wird man sucht immer noch nach dem
Handy von Josefine es gibt hier in der
Nähe auch ein See wo man vielleicht
vermutet dass es da reingeschmissen
worden sein könnte da kommen heute
vielleicht sogar noch Taucher zum
Einsatz
welche Hinweise gibt es ansonsten dort
am Fundort
es ist
hier noch alles abgesperrt weil die
Polizei auch heute weiter hier suchen
wird in in den Bereich der Garagen
man konzentriert sich wirklich jetzt
erstmal auf die Spurensicherung es gibt
wie ich gerade von der Polizei erfahre
habe noch keinen konkreten Tatverdacht
ist wird einfach weiter gesucht man
guckt jetzt was man hier noch findet
natürlich läuft die Auswertung der
Spuren die die Tatortgruppe gestern
gesichert hat im Landeskriminalamt die
Leiche wird obduziert die ist noch in
der Nacht abtransportiert worden und man
hat gesagt es wird heute wahrscheinlich
im Laufe des Tages auch weitere
Entwicklungen geben und da müssen wir
einfach abwarten wie sich die Dinge
entwickeln noch keinen konkreten
Tatverdacht sagst du gerade Thilo
irgendwie steht ja schon der Ex-Freund
dort im Mittelpunkt mit ihm war sie
verabredet an diesem Tag und kehrte eben
nie wieder zurück und dann wird ihre
Leiche jetzt auch nicht ganz so weit
entfernt zwei Kilometer entfernt von
diesem Treffpunkt der beiden gefunden
warum hat es lange gedauert ihn
möglicherweise mehr an den Mittelpunkt
der Ermittlungen zu stellen oder warum
hat er steht er nicht unter Tatverdacht
man muss sagen zum jetzigen Zeitpunkt
ist es wirklich so er ist ein Zeuge er
wurde mehrfach vernommen er wurde
mindestens viermal vernommen immer im
Beisein seiner Eltern es handelt sich
bei dem jungen er ist 15 Jahre alt ja
noch um einen nicht volljährigen
deshalb
hat die Polizei auch in Übereinstimmung
mit den Eltern freiwillig einer
Durchsuchung der Wohnung vorgenommen
hier hat die Familie selber keine Garage
man guckt jetzt wem die zugeordnet
werden kann deshalb hier gibt es
verschiedene Wildkameras die die
Garagenbesitzer angebracht haben das
Material dieser Kameras werdet die
Polizei auch aus weil man natürlich
Hoffnung hat vielleicht irgendwelche
Bewegungsbilder zu sehen ob man sehen
kann dass hier jemand angekommen ist in
den letzten Tagen denn immerhin ist ja
Josefine seit Donnerstag dem 4 November
verschwunden gewesen
ILO scheut die sekk unsere Reporter dort
am Fundort der Leiche von Josefine in
Aschersleben vielen herzlichen Dank und
wir wollen weiter über diesen
entsprechende mit Kriminalist Christian
Matzdorf uns jetzt direkt auch
zugeschaltet er wird analysieren was der
Fundort Aussagen könnte über diese Tat
schön dass Sie bei uns in Kontakt haben
Alsdorf ja der Fundort was konnte der
Aussagen über diese Tat
der Fundort ist für die kriministischen
Ermittlungen genauso bedeutend wie der
noch nicht bekannte Tatort vielleicht
sind auch Fundort und Tatort identisch
das wissen wir heute Montag noch nicht
dieser Ort ist natürlich ein Fundus an
Spuren und er gibt möglicherweise
Hinweise darauf ob die Täter oder der
Täter ein Bezug zu diesem Ort hatten
also sie hatten selber gerade gesagt ist
diese Garage einer Person zuzuordnen ist
dieser Bereich dort vielleicht Personen
oder Personengruppen zuzuordnen das
alles ist relevant für die Ermittlung
momentan und daher auch der Einsatz der
Kriminaltechnik die natürlich jetzt alle
spurenarten von DNA-Spuren
möglicherweise das Teleskope Spuren
vielleicht Faserspuren hier auswertete
nachdem sie die gesichert haben sie
haben sich jeden Fall genau angeschaut
Herr Matzdorf wenn Sie die Fotos sehen
vom Fundort der Leiche von Josefine wenn
sie die Geschichte mit dem Ex-Freund
kennen ja die beiden waren verabredet
was ist jetzt auch anhand der Fotos die
entscheidende Spur die sie weiter Verf
was die
Beziehungssituation des Mädchens
anbelangt muss man vorsichtig sein wir
dürfen nicht
wir dürfen nicht spekulieren
selbstverständlich wir wissen aber aus
der kriministischen Erfahrung und auch
aus der kriminologischen Theorie dass
insbesondere Frauen ganz besonders
gefährdet sind in Trennungssituationen
das gilt Regelfall für erwachsene
Menschen in Situationen die unter
Erwachsenen sich ergeben Trennung nach
entsprechende Beziehung das ist aber
auch bei Jugendlichen nicht
auszuschließen also insofern ist das
hier sicherlich eine Spur die die
Polizei mit Hochdruck verfolgen wird
spekulieren dürfen wir nicht was den Ort
selber angeht ist natürlich geeignet um
einen Leichnamen für eine gewisse Zeit
zu verbergen sicherlich nicht geeignet
um dauerhaft in leichter dort zu
belassen also man muss schon überlegen
was Täter oder Täterinnen weiter
vorgehabt haben das heißt wir müssen in
die kriministische thesenbildung
reingehen und müssen über verschiedene
Varianten verschiedene Alternativen hier
prüfen abwägen und das macht die Polizei
gerade mit Hochdruck
vielen herzlichen Dank Christian Mazda
für ihre Einschätzungen zu diesem Fall